[Music]
on parks and rec you guys did something
that got a lot of attention vice
president biden yeah did a cameo yeah on
the show
and i understand you got to spend time
with the vice president i did um i got
to go to the white house and i've
actually met him before twice
and every time i see him he
he's really good at making me feel like
we're old friends
which is nice sure
he's really warm and and um
and uh and he he's from delaware so we
have a lot in common which is right
where i met him before and um and he
actually
let us take like a little tour of his
office which was cool and um and i stole
something off his desk so that also
happened you stole something off the
vice president's desk in the white house
yeah i was gonna bring it to show you
but um i couldn't find it
because
i think i put it in like side of a book
under my
bed or something but um he
yeah he let us in his office and we were
walking around it was like me and i
don't know if i'm supposed to say this
uh that you yeah you went into the vice
president's office and stole something
from his desk which by now you which and
also you've lost it now these could be
are these sensitive documents yes i
think i just realized that i shouldn't
be saying this yeah
i think i'm trapped now okay
this is my favorite kind of interview
then so he let he let us in his office
and we were walking around and i was
with chris pratt who was just here i
think and amy and and he was like have
fun in there and um and you'd think that
the the white house would i don't know
if i should talk about
well you think that the white house
should feel like
there's like a lot of cameras everywhere
or like security sure but it didn't feel
that way to me because i kept walking
around like pretending like i had an
earpiece in and i kept going uh copy and
walking slowly to the thing
and i thought like someone would jump
out at me and be like you're suspicious
yeah but
nothing no and then um
chris pratt pointed to joe joe i'm gonna
call him joe
joe's death sure and was like look your
name and there was a card on his desk on
a vice president
stationary that said my name underline
and then it had bullet points of facts
about
my life and then and then at the bottom
so that he could when he met you he
could say like oh and then he could
you know remember you and you could
think oh he really i know i remember
everything about you you were born on
june 26th right right um and stuff like
that and then at the bottom it said like
aubry claims she met you at a youth
leadership conference
um and she was the last speaker of
parentheses according to her so it was a
little snarky too
and then it's like they don't believe
you yeah it's like they should have said
no way she's a closer yeah yeah i know
that just is so rude like according to
her anyway well you know it's probably
his assistant or something and and she
you know i don't blame her but anyway i
stole it i like sneakily like slit it in
my pocket yeah and i was really scared
because i was like i'm stealing from the
white house
um
but no one caught me and then i lost it
okay
i was like i'm gonna frame it and not
keep it forever and now it's probably
like
crumpled up
no i'm sure you're gonna find it you've
gotta find it i'm sure there's a swat
team at your house right now looking i
know i still um get scared at night
sometimes that they're gonna come for
the piece of paper yeah
yeah
they have powers
you've made a terrible mistake
i i know i've made so many mistakes
i know i'm going to be punished for one
of them someday
well uh let's talk about your name
i like any interview that just con it
ends with i've made so many mistakes
i'll be punished for them one day i'll
get mine i think the show should just
fade to black now
hey you recently